Hello, internet.
I'm Gavin.
I'm Dan.
We're the slow-mo guys.
A lot of the time I see an image
and think that's a really cool image,
but the image, obviously
it's just one single frame.
Let's add lots of frames,
either side of that.
And today's subject is
a spinning foam ball.
Yeah, we've got this one here.
Gonna get it covered in water,
dip it in there and spin it,
and hopefully it'll look
like Saturn or something.
Or like some sort
Yeah.
of rings around it.
Gives the impression
of the way that the water spirals out,
it looks like a galaxy, almost.
'Cause it comes out as
the thing is turning
just like a super-massive black hole
in the middle of a galaxy.
Ooh.
We'll try different colors as well
and different angles.
Yep.
And let's give it a go.
Let's do it.
So you gonna be there?
Over there.
Yep.
Three, two, one.
Is that good?
All right, let me focus.
Probably going to get
off a little bit too.
All right, I can track it.
Ready?
Yeah, go for it.
Yeah.
Three, two one!
That was cool!
Did you get wet?
Yes, I got wet.
Spinning a foam pool toy covered in water
in front of my face.
At exactly face splashing height.
Yeah.
Three, two, one.
Good.
Yeah?
It deforms massively when you do it.
Yeah.
I gotta impart enough pressure
onto it to actually spin it.
That's the thing.
Ah.
Look at that.
That looks pretty cool.
We recreated that pretty
faithfully to the image.
Yep.
Nailed it.
Usually I like to add a
bit of a slimy gross touch
to everything we recreate
and that usually involves
you getting hurt in some way.
Yeah, I was just wondering
how this could happen.
Yeah, I figured this one
we'll just give you a break
and maybe just add some
coloring to the water.
Sounds good.
Got some food coloring?
Luckily I carry -
Always.
Multiple packets
all the time.
Neon!
Got neon, assorted, and assorted premium.
Well, hopefully we'll work
our way up to premium.
Okay, so this is actually
the premium blue we're using.
Oh, straight to premium.
Straight to premium.
Wow.
No messing around, this is slimer budget.
Aye, obviously budget, high budget.
Fill this plastic bucket that we've got
with the sponge ball in it with water.
At this rate, this video
will break double digits
in terms of how much it costs to produce.
I got a discount.
Oh you did?
Yeah.
Cool.
Oh, that's lovely.
Oh.
That's what we want.
Ah, blue.
Three, two, one!
Your eyes!
Did it say anything
about getting food coloring in your eyes?
Don't know.
Probably.
That's some concentrated purple.
Back in the day, you would have -
Paid a mint for that.
Paid an absolute mint.
Highly sought after color, that one.
Oh man, that is deep -
Deep purple?
What's that song by Deep Purple?
"Hush"?
No.
Three, two, one.
I mean, this is cool and everything,
but I just feel like
it's not a complete video
without me getting hit with it.
Do you think you could throw it at me?
I mean, as much as I hate doing it,
I think you're right.
I think we do have to just
launch it at your face.
Yeah.
Feeling comfortable?
Yes, I'm feeling comfy.
Nice.
Yeah, all about that.
Here.
Nice sunny day.
You all right there?
You going to be okay?
Oh!
Goodness me!
What?
Oh.
That all right?
Rowed my head!
Sorry!
Absolutely rowed me!
That hurt a lot more
than I thought it would!
It was just a foam ball.
Yeah, but it's full of water!
Oh, did I get you?
Little bit, yeah.
Sorry.
I thought that looked very, very lovely.
It was kind of artsy.
Actually did sort of a little
bit look like a galaxy.
Got some nice spirals on the go.
Yeah.
Tried a variety of colors.
One color we didn't try.
I'm out.
Aw! Why?
Okay.
Well, feel free to follow us on Twitter.
Subscribe.
Buy a shirt if you want.
You always do this!
Maybe next time.
Flameproof suits.
I very flukily lined up
your body with your legs.
Does it look good?